NARRATOR: What will you
do when calamity strikes?
A survival situation may
be unlikely for humans,
but for animals in the wild,
preparing for
disaster is their day job.
Good planning can
mean the difference
between life and death.
From cutting edge engineering,
to elaborate escape strategies.
We're taking notes on how
these animals prepare for
emergency situations, in
the world's weirdest ways.
When faced with chaos,
the greatest weapon,
is a plan.
(theme music plays)
Winter in North America.
Like a scene from
the end of the world.
Food is scarce.
And with hungry
raiders on the prowl,
getting caught out
in the open can mean,
a grisly end.
But in this frozen wasteland,
a fortress stands defiant.
Steam rises from its chimney.
Something inside, is alive.
What could have built,
this emergency bunker?
Just a few months before
the onslaught of winter,
the forest is
abuzz with activity.
It's not chainsaws,
but jaws at work.
The American beaver.
These plant eating
rodents may seem docile,
but they're about to
transform their habitat,
in an extraordinary
animal renovation project!
Phase one,
collecting building material.
Beavers have
four iron-infused,
chisel-sharp incisors that
keep growing all throughout
their lives and
never wear out.
They can munch their
way through a small tree,
six inches thick, in
a matter of minutes.
Next, they'll need to
transport the wood to the
construction site, but
no trucks or cranes here.
Beavers use canal highways
to float their cargo home.
Their paddle tails and
duck-like feet can propel them
through water at up
to five miles an hour!
And now, they execute phase
two of their bunker project;
the beaver dam.
The trickling sound of leaking
water triggers one of the
beaver's strongest instincts.
Build, build, build!
This creates a
large defensive moat,
in which they construct the
final phase: the beaver lodge.
They pile up rocks, branches
and logs as high as six feet
above the water, and weather
seal the structure with mud.
They'll need to work fast:
autumn is about to end.
But the best laid plans, can
attract unwanted attention.
The beavers have
been stocking up twigs
and branches underwater.
Food to last through winter.
And this hulking moose is
just reaping all the benefits.
No plan and no permission.
But how do you
stop someone almost
30 times your body weight?
The beaver's paddle
tail makes a loud splash.
A stern warning, and also an
alarm call for other beavers.
Size doesn't matter,
when you've got attitude.
The beaver lodge is complete,
in time for the
late November snow.
This astonishing structure
is more than just a shelter,
it's got secure
underwater entrances,
multiple rooms, and
even a ventilation shaft.
And now that the mud
walls have frozen solid,
this bunker is
virtually impenetrable.
These little emergency
planners may have created the
safest place to ride out
the winter armageddon.
It's certainly not easy to build
a survival hideout from scratch,
so what if you didn't need to?
The warm waters of
the indo-pacific.
This is an unforgiving
fish-eat-fish world.
Apex predators are on patrol,
and deadly traps
are ready to spring.
If you're a small
fish in this big pond,
it's probably
going to end in teeth.
These colorful
clownfish, however,
have discovered an
unusual place to bunker down;
among the stinging
tentacles of a sea anemone.
There are over 1,000 species
of sea anemone in the ocean.
But don't be fooled, they
are nothing like the innocent
flowers they're named after.
Sea anemones are
meat-eating killer fish traps!
With the slightest touch,
it injects a venomous
neurotoxin into its prey,
strong enough
to paralyze a small fish.
The tentacles drag
the helpless fish
into its central mouth,
where it's digested whole!
They may be clownfish,
but they're no clowns.
Sheltering in the arms
of a predator takes a
special kind of preparation.
Scientists believe that
clownfish brush themselves
carefully against
the tentacles,
until a layer of anemone
mucous covers the fish.
This fools the
anemone into accepting it.
Clownfish aren't the only
ones to befriend this killer.
Smaller sea anemones are a
hot commodity in the field
of underwater security.
As part of the hermit
crab's bizarre survival plan,
it gathers up sea
anemones to use as bodyguards.
Hermit crabs don't
have armor of their own,
so they hide out in shells
discarded by other animals.
And this one's
got a sea anemone,
pre-installed!
But one isn't always enough.
Sea anemones like staying put.
They grip on to hard surfaces
with a large disc-like foot.
This hermit crab
knows just the trick.
A slight tickle here,
an easy lift.
His moves are so smooth that
the anemone doesn't even close
up during the procedure.
An octopus has
spotted his prey.
He pounces on the crab, but
gets a mouthful of anemone.
He tries again.
The meal is striking back.
It's not worth his trouble.
And the hermit
crab's mobile fortress
is a stinging success.
NARRATOR: You may have
think you've seen weird,
but things get even weirder
when sea anemones go to war,
with each other.
That's because two
families struggle to
share a single boulder.
The science of genetics has
taught us that the need to
protect and spread
DNA is a basic
driver of animal behavior.
The aggregating sea anemone of
the Pacific U.S. coast has
taken that to extremes.
It can reproduce sexually by
releasing sperm and eggs into
the sea to drift and mingle.
But weirdly they also multiply
by cloning themselves;
splitting in half
like dividing cells.
Through cloning they can
rapidly colonize every nearby
space with genetically
identical copies of themselves.
The more crowded their living
conditions the better they are
able to withstand the constant
daily drought they face
during low tide.
And by cloning each anemone,
they ensure that its territory
is dominated only
by its own DNA.
Until two growing colonies
of assembled anemones come
tentacle to tentacle.
The two colonies are the same
species but carry different DNA.
They're in a permanent
war of attrition for
possession of this boulder.
The anemone clones on the
front lines of this war have
developed stinging clubs,
which they use to fight off
the advancing enemy anemone.
The warrior clones on
the battlefront can
die from repeated strikes.
Or do they?
Each animal in this army is
genetically the same animal,
so weirdly; they can die,
yet still live on in others.
So the clone war goes on.
Lungfish are an ancient fish
that can be found in Africa,
South America and Australia.
They live in the murky
margins of swamps and rivers.
But sometimes, water can
dry up during droughts.
Lungfish have found a way
around this fundamental problem.
Their strange mutation has
enabled them to survive for
more than 300 million years.
When their
watery home vanishes;
lungfish turn to
breathing air like a mammal.
Droughts can last
for years on end.
So the lungfish digs down
in mud to create a burrow.
Where it coats
itself in mucous,
which dries to a
leathery body-bag,
protecting it from
total dehydration.
The lungfish then shuts
its system down and waits.
It can survive for years
if that's what it takes.
The lake and the fish
may be long forgotten,
but the lungfish
will still be there.
Its metabolic
rate drops by 60%.
What little
energy it does need,
comes from slowly
consuming its own muscles.
It effectively eats
itself to survive.
When the drought
breaking deluge finally comes,
the lungfish awakens
from its dormant state,
re-animated and ready to roll.
On an evolutionary scale,
this was a game changer,
that's kept the lungfish
alive since before dinosaurs.
Some weird animals have
developed battle plans that
can defeat the enemy,
without even touching them.
The dry, red earth of
Africa's Kalahari desert.
Meerkats have banded together
in a tribal community.
While the mob turns up the
dirt in search of breakfast,
one adult takes on
the critical role, of sentry.
He stands upright on the
highest lookout for over an
hour at a time, where
he can spot predators from
more than half a mile away.
His persistent
call reassures the
gang that the coast is clear.
But at the first
sign of danger,
he uses one of 30 distinct
messages to warn his
family of the threat.
(alarm call)
This time, it's a cape cobra.
Among the most
dangerous snakes in Africa.
With venom so potent,
it could kill a grown
man in 30 minutes.
Many creatures would run
from this deadly adversary.
But not the meerkats,
they stand their ground.
They've got a plan.
For the meerkats,
the best fight,
is no fight at all.
They dart their
heads back and forth,
spit and growl menacingly.
It's an elaborate
intimidation display,
a bluff to
discourage the snake.
But there's more to this plan.
Multiple moving targets
can confuse the predator.
The snake has
difficulty singling out
and attacking its prey.
It's all too much
for the cape cobra,
and it makes a
tactical retreat.
The meerkat mafia have made
an offer it can't refuse.
You mess with one, you
mess with all of the family.
NARRATOR: We've seen
the most amazing defenses:
playing dress-up,
playing house, playing offense.
But this weaverbird has a
different kind of defense
strategy to avoid predators:
an excellent home
security system.
Of course, as with
any good real estate,
it's all about location.
He's found an
acacia tree with
everything a potential
mate could want;
a water view, shade,
and most importantly,
viciously sharp thorns to keep
most predators away.
The custom built home
doesn't hurt either.
Male weavers build intricate,
tightly woven nests.
If the female is
happy with her
general contractor's design,
she moves in.
Weavers depend upon their
construction skills to keep
their hatchlings safe.
Usually, it works.
But it doesn't stop the
predators from trying.
The noisy, boisterous
colony is attracting some
unwanted attention.
This snake wants
eggs for breakfast.
As it carefully
winds its way around the
thorns towards a nest,
a weaver sounds
the burglar alarm.
(chirping)
With a few deft moves,
the weaver dumps his
nemesis into the drink.
Fending off this
attacker won't be so easy.
The gabar goshawk can
perch right on the nest.
Actually breaking into
it is a little harder.
But all it takes is
one little design flaw and
the hatchlings are toast.
Even with all
their precautions,
for the weavers,
this is still a pretty
dangerous neighborhood.
The weaver bird's weird look
out call takes the passive
approach to survival.
But when your enemy is
mother nature herself,
the best defense of all
is to get out of town.
Deep in the amazon rainforest,
the ground is ablaze
with the tiny terror,
of the fire ant.
A torrent of soldiers!
Armed to the teeth
with a burning bite,
they strip
animals to the bone.
Its sting contains
cell-destroying venom that
wreaks havoc on
even human flesh.
This flaming horde of
ants seems unstoppable.
But when the
rainy season comes,
the amazon brings out
nature's extinguisher:
an epic flood of
biblical proportions!
Over 100,000 square miles
of forest submerged under
some 40 feet of water.
The end is surely nigh.
But not even water can
douse this ingenious inferno!
The ants join together.
Their bodies combine
to form an incredible,
floating ark!
They trap tiny bubbles
of air around themselves
to increase their buoyancy.
This miraculous raft can
stay afloat for months on end.
But the journey is
fraught with peril.
Their most precious
cargo is the colony's queen.
Their future
depends on her survival,
so she stays dry,
literally trampling on
her royal subjects.
The lower peasants are
picked off one by one,
like floating
clumps of fish food.
Some will drown.
But she's a queen to die for!
Finally, landfall.
The ants haul 'her
highness' to safety.
The dynasty has found salvation
on their self-made ark.
And now they return
to what they do best:
spreading their wildfire.
Even against a
catastrophic emergency,
the fire ants blaze on.
Getting a move on is a
well-known survival strategy.
For mother turtles, her
journey is all about going home.
She often gets credit
for being a good mother.
But really, she's
just a good navigator.
Seven different species
roam the world's oceans.
When it's time to have babies,
mothers are famous for finding
their way back to the
exact place they were born.
One turtle with a satellite
tag was recorded making a
journey of over 12,000 miles.
That kind of painstaking
precision is only for
getting to the beach.
Once they arrive, it's
chaos: a fin- flapping,
sand-kicking free for all.
This mother green turtle
may dig several nests and lay
multiple clutches of
eggs over a season.
She can navigate the globe.
But can't quite remember
where she dug her last nest.
The eggs she accidentally digs
up tonight could even be the
ones she laid last month.
The morning sun
bakes them to a crisp.
As the season wears on,
mother turtles
continue to arrive.
Eggs begin to hatch even
as mothers are still nesting.
Once again, mom doesn't
seem to notice or care.
These babies she's
steamrolling could
very well be hers.
Not her problem.
She just wants to add another
100 eggs to the season total.
Throughout the world, all
sea turtle mothers leave their
babies to fend for themselves.
The little ones have to
make a mad dash to the sea,
across a killing field.
No parental protection, and
every predator on the beach
gunning for them.
Their chances
are one in 1,000.
Any baby that survives
the ordeal remains easy
prey for ocean predators.
It won't reach breeding
age for another ten years.
Sure she's not the cuddliest
mother but playing the numbers
game isn't a bad bet.
She could produce thousands
of young in her lifetime.
If more than two of those
survive long enough to breed,
that's called winning.
NARRATOR: Our next weird
creature is the envy of
pregnant women everywhere.
The giant sea horse is
neither gigantic nor a horse.
Instead, it's a foot-long
fish that lives in the
Pacific Ocean.
But its name isn't
nearly as mixed up as
the way it reproduces.
It starts off simple.
Boy meets girl,
a brief courtship,
tails intertwine.
The newly minted couple
will stay together
throughout the breeding season.
About that breeding, the
female makes the eggs.
But instead of
growing them inside her,
or depositing them on the
ocean floor like most fish,
she deposits them in the guy.
A specialized pouch
in his belly opens up
to receive the eggs.
She floats away.
He fertilizes the eggs and
takes over the heavy-duty work
of incubating their offspring
over the next few weeks.
Why does the male eat
for several hundred?
Reproduction is
energy intensive.
By sharing the baby burden,
it gives the female
a chance to invest her
energy in laying
the next round of eggs.
More eggs means more chances
some offspring will survive.
The father finds out
the hard way when the young
are ready to emerge.
He experiences a set of
intense contractions.
No lamaze
classes for this guy.
He just suffers through it.
And up to 400 children
wriggle free and swim away.
And he looks for
his mate to start the
painful process over again.
That's just mixed up.
Parenting styles are as
varied as in the human world.
You've got tiger moms,
helicopter dads,
the free-rangers,
and worry warts.
But when the only rule
children have to obey is
survival of the fittest, there
are bound to be problems.
A pair of snowy egrets
makes a handsome young couple.
They're graceful,
and elegantly dressed.
But this picture-perfect
family hides a dirty
little secret.
A murder is about
to be committed,
and nobody's
ruffling a feather over it.
Snowy egrets inhabit
the waterways of the US,
Central and South America.
This pair in Florida have
three little hatchlings.
They share the
work of raising them.
Taking turns, stalking
the shallow salt marsh,
spearing small
fish and crustaceans,
and shuttling food
back to the nest.
There's one thing that
doesn't seem to concern them:
it's what the kids
are up to at home.
The two oldest chicks
are getting stronger
and more aggressive.
While the youngest
only gets weaker.
At first the older chicks
just shove it out of the way.
But then they begin to stab and
beat their younger sibling.
(growl)
Mom's right there.
Does she intervene?
No, she turns a blind eye.
As far as these parents are
concerned three chicks is more
than they can feed this year.
So they let the kids
settle it themselves.
The parents may not care,
but at least there's one
bystander who does.
The evidence is
quickly erased.
Mom and dad
keep up appearances
like nothing happened.
A little family murder
is swept under the rug.
Bizarre behavior can strike
some of the world's most
famous mothers and fathers;
Antarctica's emperor penguins.
Their dedication to
their young is legendary.
Almost immediately
after laying the egg,
mother penguins march
to the sea on a food run.
While fathers endure the
coldest winter on earth,
incubating the pair's
precious egg until it hatches.
It's a brutal three months,
taking a toll on eggs and
new-borns alike.
Mothers return with bellies
full of fish for their young.
Unfortunately, they're also
carrying a recipe for madness.
Their blood is
coursing with prolactin;
a powerful hormone that
stimulates parental behavior
in both males and females.
Most mothers reunite with
their mate and instantly bond
with a chick they've
never seen before.
But for those whose
chicks have died,
there's no reunion.
Her parental
hormones are still raging.
She searches the mob
for a chick to nurture.
Any chick.
Even if it means kidnapping.
The real parents fight to
keep control of their baby.
In the melee a
chick can be crushed,
sometimes by its own
mother and father.
Occasionally the
imposters win the battle.
But the chick's unfamiliar
call doesn't trigger their
instinct to feed it.
Once their madness
passes, they lose interest.
Leaving the chick
hungry and alone.
Where temperatures
hover at 20 below zero,
injured chicks
don't survive long.
Nature's weirdest ironic twist
proves that you can have too
much of a good thing.
Even the most positive
parental urges can
have a sinister side.
NARRATOR: The survival of
the weird just got weirder.
Meet the thresher shark.
It may be one of the most
recognizable fish in the ocean.
The long tail propels it
forward in perpetual motion.
Sharks like the thresher are
one of just a few kinds of
animal that never
come to a stop.
They are ram ventilators,
meaning they can only breathe
as long as they
are moving forward,
and water is
flushing past their gills.
For the thresher,
to stop is to die.
But the thresher shark's
enormously long whip-like tail
is also put to work in the
world's weirdest shark attack.
This small-mouthed,
small toothed shark hunts
mostly small schooling fish.
The shark's long tail provides
the speed and maneuverability
necessary to chase these fish.
When the thresher can find
a tightly packed school,
it uses an extremely
rare hunting technique,
unique among sharks.
It drives forward and down
flipping its tail over its head,
and cracking it like a whip.
The tip of the thresher's tail
has been measured moving at
almost 50 miles an hour.
It strikes with enough energy
that several fish at a time
can be taken out with
its high-speed tail slap.
The thresher's tail generates
enough force to propel the
shark right out of
the water if necessary.
For small sharks and fish,
surviving a close call with an
angel shark is a rare event.
Angel sharks have fallen so
far from the shark family tree
that they are virtually
subterranean in lifestyle.
But they may be the
premier ambush hunters
of the shark world.
Unusual in sharks,
the angel appears to be
largely a visual hunter,
but one with weird
and extreme capabilities.
Angel sharks will
settle to the bottom and
gently bury themselves.
Setting a trap of
impressive proportions.
They may wait days in
this position for
prey to pass overhead.
Then this booby-trap of a
shark erupts from the sand,
and strikes!
In just a tenth of a second it
can arch its body upward in a
lightning fast attack.
They've been seen charging
at anything that passes by.
They may spit the
food out afterwards
if they don't want it.
A shark that has to wait for
prey to pass overhead can't
afford to be picky.
The darkness of night isn't
an obstacle for this shark's
hair-trigger hunting style.
But in a weird twist,
it can't see in the dark
like many night hunters can.
Instead, the angel shark's
eyes appear to have evolved to
detect the faint glow of
bioluminescent plankton that
will light up in the
wake of a passing fish.
A rare example of
indirect detection.
The angel shark can't
see its prey at night,
but it can detect the
microscopic animals that
detect its prey.
The angel shark's abilities
are a stunning example of what
hundreds of millions of years
of trial and error can do.
(howl)
NARRATOR: These are the
survivalists of the wild.
Preparing for the
most extreme circumstances
in the world's weirdest ways.
Ready to hide, ready to fight.
And in a losing battle,
ready with an exit plan.
The North American
bobcat is a hunter with
a wide range of tastes.
It's looking for an easy
meal and has this harmless
hognose snake in its sights,
but this little snake knows
how to act like it's dangerous;
hissing, and flaring
like a cobra's hood.
(hissing)
Seeming to be big
and bad, often works.
But bobcats
aren't easily fooled.
The snake's
problem just got bigger,
so the hognose must dig
deeper into its bag of tricks.
With high drama,
it plays dead.
It even exudes a
rotting smell to kill
the bobcat's curiosity.
Great hunters like the
bobcat prefer fresh meat,
and little appetite for a
dish of stinking dead snake.
The snake knows this and gives
the performance of its life.
When the bobcat gives up and
goes in search of a better meal,
the little
mutant's problem is solved.
It takes a bow,
and exits stage left.
The markets of
Jaipur, India are under
constant threat from bandits,
waiting for
an unsuspecting target.
This gang of langur
monkeys is devious,
relentless and worst
of all, untouchable.
Monkeys are symbols
of the Hindu gods.
Harming them is a
religious offense.
The most the fruit seller
can do is shoo them away.
The monkey's biggest
threat comes from each other.
They form rival gangs, roaming
the streets and fighting
turf wars over access to
the ample supply of food.
As India becomes
more urbanized,
expect more monkey mafias.
An unstoppable menace.
But one that can
be weirdly cute.
Autumn leaves are
already starting to fall,
and with them, the
last morsels of food.
Now is the time for grey
squirrels to put their
emergency plan into action,
storing away protein-rich
nuts for winter.
It seems like an
innocent activity,
but what's astonishing
about these hoarders,
is their devious,
tactical mind.
They're well versed in
the art of espionage.
It's the acorn cold war.
A stealthy spy
watches from above,
waiting for a squirrel to
reveal her nut hiding spot so
he can steal it for himself.
But he's been busted.
The squirrel on the ground
knows she's being watched.
And she puts on a show.
She digs a hole,
as usual, but,
with a little sleight of hand,
she escapes
without burying anything.
The spy swoops in,
and he's been duped.
The nut has already been
squirreled away to another,
more secret location.
It's hard enough to keep track
of hundreds of buried nuts.
Much harder when nature
covers it all in white.
But the squirrel is a
master of mental gymnastics.
It remembers landmarks,
like trees and buildings,
and triangulates a mental
map of its hidden stashes.
It's believed that squirrels
can locate a nut up to nine
months after it was buried!
With not only
phenomenal memory,
but the ability to deceive,
the remarkable grey squirrel
is a forward thinker,
with a license to live.
Captioned by Cotter
Captioning Services.